[Musique]
peut pas ne pas tomber en amour on
appelle cela du bois sans bon l'amérique
bomy on ne revient jamais les mains
vides d'une promenade en forêt c'est la
conviction du matapédien marcel bout si
je t'avais deuxième on a au moins jeunes
de plans de séquoias des bois aime vivre
selon les saisons et les forêts qui
l'entourent
il récupère écoles de tout ce qui se
trouve sur son territoire avec et par
respect de la nature
si j'ai des bêlements point de vue c'est
un moment spécial maillot jaune au
québec présentement que ce soit pour la
cueillette de fruits et de plantes pour
se nourrir et se soigner ou encore de la
récupération de matières brutes pour
créer chaque trouvaille forêt serbe pour
lui une grande utilité
le tout doit se résoudre à main de la
dame on se trouve aux autres mandats
wasson la patronne qui je peux faire un
genre de colle pour travailler il joue
[Musique]
juge blanc la forêt pour tous vos
questions ou de bien faire avec
puis j'explore côté artisanal que ce que
je pourrais créer deux coauteurs du
bonheur avec ce que j'ai donné un bout
d'os d'orignal se transforme en couteau
un goût de branches en cuillère depuis
hier son but
conscientiser la population à la valeur
importante des ressources forestières et
surtout à la protection de sa
biodiversité choix que quand on chez
veille que
la mondialisation n'est pas
nécessairement bon je vais recommander
aux fachos la gaspésie que ça c'est le
choix d'ali ce sens est aujourd'hui sur
une quand on joue un bon tour joué sur
cinq ans d'un sapin qui est en train de
mourir mais je vois bien dans un beau
breton maintenant tout le monde le sait
il ya peu au courant qu est-ce qui on a
du coup pouvait capable de manger sion
avant chez eux puis de deux nuitées des
unités détachement pour mieux c'est
pourquoi il donne des ateliers de
vulgarisation de cueillette et de
techniques de séchage de plantes
sauvages un partenariat avec la
municipalité de la matapédia
mais je rentre les écoles puis je vois
souvent par woods 4e 5e année ils ont
les anime et là-dessus levier que la
quenouille challenge piqué on peut faire
des bons plans avec show l'explorateur
des bois fournit également les artisans
avec la matière brute qu'on peut trouver
en fondant ce jeune homme
ici jeff boudreault radio-canada amqui
ici bas saint laurent